[Music]
what's up chuck uh mora bob what is
happening what what what happened to
neil what did you do with neil did you
well you know did you put neal in low
earth orbit bro
yeah yeah i know i think i think i think
neil is is is somewhere between here and
the moon um or orbiting around and uh
yeah today we're going to do an
explainer video together if that's okay
with you yeah i love it man i love it
well hopefully it'll be something about
all of the uh things that are floating
around this planet
making our front yard look like that we
we belong in uh how shall i put it a
lower economic neighborhood
you know it's we've already heard about
elon and spacex launching all these
satellites the starlinks to provide
global internet and in fact uh these
things have been providing internet and
ukraine which is kind of a key thing so
so it's been a good thing that these
things have been on orbit so let me ask
you before you go any further because
we're talking about starling because i
don't really know that much about it i
do know about i heard about the the
launch and the satellites being deployed
but what is the benefit of having all of
these satellites because we have
internet right now so what's the benefit
of having all these tiny little
satellites all over the place
yeah so that's a great question so
the benefit of the satellites is that
even though
you and i have internet here in the u.s
and it's almost like ubiquitous there's
actually
many regions around the globe that have
zero internet whatsoever nothing
gotcha
and and so and so so if we want to get
knowledge and i know neil kind of cares
about this thing and so do you if we
want to get knowledge to be
ubiquitous across humanity
the internet is a great way to to do
that and
from space if we can have all these
satellites providing this internet then
you know in theory there's no part of
the globe that would be without internet
and is that a direct link to starlink is
it like i don't have to go through some
kind of isp or something like that i'm
just getting directly beamed down like
elon musk is beaming me the signal or is
it something different no yeah so elon
uh is beating you the signal and you do
have to have some equipment right uh to
receive it but but yeah as long as you
have a receiver you can get the internet
oh wow okay
that actually is kind of important
and i let me tell you something i love
hating on elon musk i love hating on all
of them to be honest i can't i got i
can't lie okay but i you know that's
that's actually kind of a good thing
absolutely and so yeah i mean you know
we could be in the middle of nowhere i
don't know somewhere in the serengeti
we're we're just chilling out uh by
lions and we could have one of these
receivers and we could have like
internet there right so okay it's like a
sap phone but for the internet exactly
wow
okay that's
i mean so so so now what's going on then
that that cuz so far
i i know that you have a problem with
stuff in space
so
i mean this seems like a good reason to
put stuff in space so what's up
yeah so look there's a good reason to
put stuff in space the thing that hasn't
been so good is that people are just
launching stuff without coordinating
with other people the traffic is
increasing we don't have traffic rules
so that's the part that's not so good
right um
but but so far it's been the elon musk's
show when it comes to the
you know the internet from space until
now
because now
turns out that jeff bezos from amazon
he's going to have his own satellite
system providing internet called kuiper
uh-oh okay now i see what we're talking
about here so now we got another
billionaire let's measure how big our
dinglings are
space race okay
pardon me anybody who's listening
well you know when it comes to
ding-a-lings uh yeah certainly it's like
uh you know now jeff is gonna jump into
this and
i mean elon proposed like 10 000
satellites which is a whole shed load of
satellites right right um and and now
jeff wants to put about 3 200 um you
know satellites in the same kind of
orbital altitude as elon which means
okay now you got elon traffic you got
junk that's just kind of kind of
floating around that's right and now
you're gonna you know lay on now you've
got bezos traffic pesos
mess
and then of course richard branson will
have to get involved you know i'm just
i'm just waiting for it to hear that
right yeah cause that's i mean honestly
they're the holy trinity
of um
a-holism okay like that's
you know if if there's a holy trinity of
a-holes it's those three guys and space
you know uh however i think it's a great
thing that they actually did kind of
spark a lot of interest in space with
what they did
i just think it was
kind of worthless i don't know maybe
well i mean look uh certainly
again you know when i look at
people across the world and
lack of knowledge that some of them have
it's a good thing for everybody to be as
knowledgeable and have as much
information about stuff as possible i
think because
not to mention porn
ex well you know you could go with that
right
that that is certainly information i
don't look i i i
that's right i don't want to be the last
person like preventing people from
getting access to to these sorts of you
know libido sort of uh data but
um but yeah i mean um i think knowledge
is definitely uneven across humanity and
the people that have more of it are
trying to exert influence and power uh
dominance over the ones that don't so i
think that kind of leveling the playing
field with information i think that's a
good thing and you know these satellites
will help you know do that okay well you
got me thinking now more but if you're
going to do something that could
possibly be detrimental
that you should also be doing something
that offsets that detriment
booyah
yep
like if you're shooting crap in the
space
you should be giving us money so that we
can pull crap out of space
that would make sense right right yeah
so so
what is happening
like
is there anything like that well the
answer is no not so much uh there should
be and what you said makes complete
sense but so far
it's mostly okay uh i can put some stuff
up there and there's this idea of this
25-year rule of um which isn't like law
is just like a suggestion hey by the way
um after your stuff stops working make
sure that it's not there
25 years after the thing dies which is a
long time so first of all that is a long
time especially when we keep shooting
crap up there
but more importantly
that's a great rule
but how
i mean you could tell people to do
whatever you want
but you got to have some way to make
that happen
exactly and to me to me that's kind of
like the jedi mind trick right those
aren't the droids you're looking for
that's not the space debris that i left
up there sort of thing it's like right
yeah we got to have enforcement man we
got to make this into a law somehow and
the 25-year thing is like too long we
needed to be much shorter than that and
i fully agree with you it's like if
you're going to be licensed to launch
some stuff up there
it it provides a service you're going to
make some money while at it which is
nothing wrong with that but it's like
clean the stuff up once you're done so
now let me ask you about these
satellites i don't know if this is
something you would know or not are they
maneuverable i mean can they get out of
the way because the last time we talked
man
i'm telling you i still haven't
recovered
from the amount of crap that you said
that's up there and then the size of
some of it that we're tracking
and i'm just thinking like okay what
about like the nuts and bolts that might
come off the stuff that could be the
disaster that starts the
you know dominoes falling so can can
these satellites get out of the way
yeah so you know elon stuff they have uh
thrusters on them so they can like move
around all the time and um you know the
kuiper satellites uh from amazon they'll
have thrusters as well for sure and i
have to tell you i've i know some of
these people personally uh colleagues
dating back uh you know decades i've
spoken to them about this sort of stuff
the cool thing is they definitely seem
on the up and up to be
behaving in a way that's long-term
sustainable and ecologically friendly
when it comes to removing stuff and so i
know that the kuiper people have plans
of de-orbiting much sooner and that sort
of thing man so so that's the good news
but yeah they can they they can move out
of the way the thing is
uh
how well can you predict when things are
going to crisscross each other uh do you
yeah do you do you know that you have to
move out of the way that's the thing
that's tough
right right so you need like an air
traffic a space traffic controller not
an air traffic controller because
there's no air in space but a space
traffic controller
also
here's my next question
are these things small enough that if
you just crash them into the atmosphere
we don't have to worry about them
yeah so so the thing is you know if you
if you basically use some fuel to
deorbit these things so that they kind
of go steeply into the atmosphere and
burn up chances are they're not going to
survive re-entry they will burn up in
the atmosphere yeah that's cool i mean
so
it's still scary to think about 3 200
things being shot and deployed
and then uh what's what's musk how many
is he doing he wants ten thousand and
ten thousand
of course that that makes sense because
he's like i'm elon musk you remember you
were talking about dinglings man so you
got uh right by the way you know bezos
has got to come up now you know that's
there's no way that he's going to just
do 32 if musk has 10 000. hey hey man
here's what i hear chuck it's what you
do with a satellite that matters right
exactly you know what i mean
it's not the size of the satellite
it's the gravity in the depravity
i don't know what that means or where it
came from you know but it sounds it's no
it's it's good
i like it
exactly yeah oh man so what is your
prediction for this outcome
because the stuff is going to go up
there what exactly what should we me
and all the people what should we be
worried about i mean or what should we
do
because this could really mess things up
yeah it could really mess things up and
the thing is you know there is the
potential for one of elon satellites to
actually collide with one of jeff bezos
satellites that would be horrible for a
variety of reasons so yeah i mean i
think the thing that we need to be
concerned about is
if we if we're saying that global
internet is a good thing everybody
should have access to information
and these satellites provide it in a
unique way cool um how do we make sure
that that is a long-term thing that can
be maintained and not to the detriment
of the environment so i think that's the
thing that we need to be concerned about
these things bumping into into each
other people keeping on launching stuff
with this kind of risk uh that these
things could collide and then pollute
the rest of the environment like you
said nuts and bolts and like become uh
many many shards so these are things
that we definitely should be worried
about for sure
all right all right man
well i have to tell you that i always
love speaking to you
and every time you're done
i feel worse
well well look man i i i'm like the
oracle in in the matrix right it's like
i got nothing but bad news but but
here's a cookie and maybe you'll feel
better i love talking to you chuck as
well all the time brother it's good all
right man
so chuck and everybody else there you
have it a quick explainer on this new
internet uh from space with jeff bezos
and project kuiper from amazon and uh my
name is morbid jaw and uh
keep on space traveling
[Applause]
[Music]
you